Belarus also direkt im nördlich der
Ukraine wir stehen uns das ganz normal
an heute morgen diese schweren Angriffe
mit Kamikaze drohen hier auf Kiew und
die Bilder die wir uns jetzt ansehen
stammen hier aus Belarus nördlich der
ukrainischen Hauptstadt und sie wecken
so ein bisschen die Angst vor dem was
wir schon gesehen haben im Januar und
Februar nämlich diese riesigen Truppen
auf Märsche an die wir uns erinnern in
Belarus und wir wollen uns gleich mal
ganz kurz das hier in Erinnerung
behalten dieses Dreieck was hier
aufgezeichnet ist bei diesem
belarussischen Militärfahrzeug nämlich
dieses Dreieck ist auch sämtlichen
militärgeräte zu erkennen was nördlich
der Grenze auffährt und wir sehen hier
BM 27 Raketenwerfer das sind
Raketenwerfer mit einer Reichweite von
etwa 35 km und dieser Aufnahmen sind nur
10 km nördlich der Grenze entstand das
heißt allein von da wo diese Aufnahmen
am Wochenende entstanden sind hätten die
Belarussen bereits schießen können haben
sie nicht bisher auf die Ukraine aber
wir sehen das hier Waffen aufgefahren
werden die eben dazu nutzen die Ukraine
anzugreifen von Norden so wie wir es im
Februar gesehen haben und wie man sich
dann aber Ende März zurückge und das
hier sind Aufnahmen ebenfalls aus
Belarus und auch die sind relativ
beeindruckend denn hier Sehnen sehen wir
russische Militärfahrzeuge russische
Fahrzeuge die also in Belarus verschifft
werden auch wie im Januar dieses Jahres
und wir sehen hier das gleiche Dreieck
hier oben das heißt wir haben diese
sogenannte von Diktator lukaschenker und
Diktator Putin genannte gemeinsame
armeegruppierung die offenbar hier etwas
plant nördlich der Ukraine und eben aus
russischen und belarussischen Einheiten
zusammen besteht die immer wieder dieses
Dreieck aufweisen als neues ja bisher
unbekanntes
militärsymbol wir erinnern uns die
Ausnahmen normalerweise das Set das V
das O und so weiter aber dieses Dreieck
sind auch hier noch mal auf den schweren
Geschützen vom Typ pion auch die mit
etwa 30 40 km Reichweite dieses Dreieck
ist überall zu sehen und scheint hier ja
nichts Gutes zu verheißen für die
Zukunft eben denn das Nordens der
Ukraine wir wollen aber auch nach
Russland gucken nämlich in die Stadt
Belgorod und dort haben uns gestern
diese Aufnahmen erreicht Panik am
Flughafen von Belgorod wir sehen wie
hier R hinten abgeschossen werden
russische
Luftabwehrraketen aber sie helfen
überhaupt nichts denn wir sehen kurz
danach hier eine mächtige Detonation auf
dem Flughafen die Leute hier in Panik
was wir hier sehen ist ein ukrainischer
Angriff auf dem Flughafen von Belgorod
auf dem militärisch genutzten Flughafen
von Belgorod und der kommt einige Tage
nachdem mehrere ukrainische Flugzeuge
über der Ukraine abgeschlossen wurden
von Flugabwehrgeschützen die hier
aufgebaut sind und dafür benutzt die
Ukraine sehr sehr sehr moderne Waffen
die sie gerade erst aus den USA bekommen
hat und wir sehen das am Ende nämlich
vom Typ AGM 88 Haram steht für
Highspeed Anti radiation missiles und
wir sehen jetzt hier gleich ein Wrack
von so einer Rakete das eben hier sehen
wir es in Belgrad gefunden wurde und wir
gucken uns mal das hier unten sind an
und erinnern uns an dieses Muster also
diese beiden roten Striche und da unter
diese Schrauben die man hier sieht und
sehen dann so eine Rakete auch an einem
Flugzeug der Ukraine festgemacht nämlich
hier und sehen hier wieder diese kleinen
Punkte und diese beiden roten Striche
und wir sehen das ist tatsächlich eine
AGM 87 eine Rakete die den Ukrainern
gegeben wurde von den Amerikanern um
eben radareinrichtung der Russen
anzugreifen und genau diese
radareinrichtungen sind hier dafür
verantwortlich dass eben in der letzten
Woche mehrere ukrainische Flugzeuge
abgeschossen würden die Ukrainer
verteidigen sich jetzt offensiv sie
haben offenbar auch das Go bzw die
Erlaubnis aus den USA bekommen dass sie
diese neuen NATO Waffen auch einsetzen
darf um eben in im Westen Russlands dort
Ziele anzugreifen damit eben die eigene
Luftwaffe sich über der Ukraine frei
bewegen kann abschließend wollen wir mit
ja ziemlich gespenstigen Bildern aus der
Ukraine nämlich einem russischen Panzer
der sich hier wie von Geisterhand dreht
und von Geisterhand sage ich tatsächlich
deshalb weil es höchstwahrscheinlich ist
das sämtliche russische Soldaten darin
tot sind oder so schwer verletzt sind
dass sie nicht mehr sich bewegen können
wir sehen hier einen Panzer der von dem
der linke die Linke Kette gebrochen ist
und der fährt deshalb immer weiter im
Kreis der dreht sich also stundenlang im
Kreis der hat offenbar noch genug Sprit
da ist aber niemand mehr drin das heißt
niemand hält du kannst daran auf sich zu
sich zu drehen und wir sehen dass dieser
eben an sich immobile Panzer weil er
eben einer der beiden Ketten abgerissen
ist die zieht er hier hinter sich her
dass der sich immer weiter im Kreis
dreht höchstwahrscheinlich mit einer
totenbesatzung also ein geisterpanzer
wenn man so möchte der hier zeigt wie
schlimm es die Russen bei diesem bei
ihrem Angriff auf die Ukraine erwischt
hat
[Musik]